got a question today that comes from the
topic of binomial theorem what we're
asked to prove is this identity now it's
pretty tough to even start if you have
no idea what ever the notation means so
let's begin first by laying down a few
ground rules okay what does it mean when
you see this pair of brackets and two
terms or expressions within that pair of
brackets just sitting on top of each
other looks like a fraction but not
really because it doesn't have the
fraction line there well that's our
definition for it's a shorthand for
really n choose R which is the the
typical binomial coefficient now what
does that mean well it means two things
number one it's how many possible ways
there are to choose or to arrange our
elements if you've got m to choose from
so for instance if I wanted to make a
team of five out of ten people the the
number of ways to do that would be ten
choose five no what does that mean well
that's shorthand again for n factorial
on our factorial n minus R factorial be
careful with those ends in ours they do
look alike okay so you need to have that
in mind because that's sort of our
building block for how we're gonna work
with this thing and lastly we also need
to remember all what is all this
factorial business men okay well if
you've got something like say in
factorial that's gonna be n multiplied
by n minus 1 multiplied by n minus 2 and
so on all the way until well depending
on the size of n you know you'll be
multiplying by three then by two then I
want you kind of counting down okay so
as an example for factorial that's four
by three by two by one okay so now that
we know what this n choose our notation
means it's binomial coefficient and what
the factorial notation means we're going
to use both of these pieces to actually
solve this okay now how you go how do
you go about it I think probably
generally if you want to prove an
identity like this or like a trig
identity or those kinds of things you
want to take one side
left-hand side of the right hand side
and then work with us simplify it until
you can get from that expression to this
expression or vice versa
okay you can choose whichever way you
like now we're just looking at this one
I would guess that we'd start from the
right hand side it's more complicated
and move to the left you know the way we
trained our brains is kind of to make
things simpler rather than to make
things more complicated so it seems to
make sense to go from two terms to one
term now you could go the other way but
I think it probably makes sense for us a
little more so I'm gonna start from the
right hand side so I'm gonna go right
hand side and when it's equal to it is
and -1 shoes off plus and minus 1 choose
R plus 1 okay now in order to work with
this at all what I want to do is bring
it back to the definition for what does
whatever choose whatever what does it
actually mean okay so if this is what
and choose R means what is n minus 1
choose R well everywhere I saw an N
factorial before I'll have an n minus 1
factorial okay so I'm gonna have on the
numerator and minus 1 factorial on now
so far that R is the same as before
okay so I'll have an R factorial here
and then I'm gonna have here I had n
minus R factorial but I don't have any
here I've got n minus 1 so I'll have n
minus 1 minus R factorial okay so
there's the first fraction right let's
do the second one it's going to be n
minus 1 factorial on the topic and then
now instead of R factorial I have R plus
1 factorial okay and then now you gotta
be careful here okay because before we
had just N and R but now I've got n
minus 1 and R plus 1 so you've got to be
careful when you take the difference
it's easy to get it wrong okay so what
I'm going to do is put in some brackets
here just to help myself out and make
sure I don't mess up the negative signs
okay so I'll have n minus 1 minus R plus
1
okay in the brackets and I think I've
sort of run out of space this factorial
okay so ah that looks terrible it looks
a lot messier than what we start with
but often to simplify these you've got
to make them things have to get worse
before they get better okay so my
question is how do I get this to look
anything like this
right well immediately you can see I'm
going to be combining two things two
fractions into one I should get one
fraction at the end of this right so if
I'm going to get two fractions into one
usually my approach for that regardless
of whether I'm dealing with just you
know numbers or thirds rational numbers
or you know binomial coefficients in
factorials I'm gonna have to get a
common denominator right so how do I get
a common denominator out of these well
before I do that let's let's simplify
this a bit that looks a bit messy I'm
gonna have n minus 1 factorial up here
it's still the same I'm gonna have an r
factor over here now even though it
doesn't make that much difference at
least in the way it's written I'm gonna
rearrange this you'll see why in a
couple of minutes so I'm gonna put that
n minus R in the middle okay the odds in
the middle rather than on the end and
then my other fraction and minus 1
factorial 1 factorial and what happens
here well I've got n minus 1 minus R but
that negative makes that a minus 1 on
the end okay so this is going to be and
minus R minus 2 factorial okay No how do
I put these together let's let's sort of
bring this aside for a minute or so here
suppose you had something similar but
with actual numbers in it okay so
suppose I was adding you asking you to
add something like this okay now if I
asked you to put these on a common
denominator how would you go about it
you could of course work out what 4
factorial is I think it's from its 4 by
3 by 2 that's 24 okay and 5 5 20 which
is 120 and then you could just simplify
as far down as you could okay
and then just get it in terms of two
common numbers that will be fine but
obviously that approach wouldn't work if
I had something like this if I said say
not four factorial but three on one
hundred factorial and two on one hundred
and one factorial
I mean computationally it's just
ridiculous what is I can factor enormous
number right which is by the way that's
why the factorial is a an exclamation
mark because the numbers just grows so
fast okay so be that I could reduce this
two numbers but it would be a bit dumb
to do it here how would I put something
like this on a common denominator well
remember what is the definition of a
factorial this 100 factorial is really
shorthand for 100 times 99 times 98
times 97 and so on all the way one so
let me just sort of write that over here
that's 108 and so on all the way down to
one what's that 101 well that's the same
kind of thing right but with a hundred
and one as your starting point all the
way down to one you can see when you
look at these two these these numbers
even though they're huge numbers they're
almost the same like all of these terms
here all of you sorry although here
right the only difference is that 101
okay so what I could do is I could
rewrite this I could say look this is
three on 100 factorial but this is two
on 101 that's the first number times 100
factorial right that's another way of
rate writing 101 factorial and this is a
lot easier to work with because now I
find what these on a common denominator
the only thing I need to do is multiply
the first fraction 501 right so yeah
excuse me okay so now that I've got that
first fraction these two now have the
same denominator namely a hundred
factorial so this is three hundred and
three and that's two and they're both
100 150 off you go okay so how can I use
that property on what I'm working with
at the moment
okay well have a look at things like
this I've got an R factorial here and
I'm going R plus one factorial here now
if I want to get these two fractions to
have the same denominator what's the
fastest way to do it well in this case
what I did was I multiplied this smaller
fraction right I'm sorry that the
denominator is smaller but the fraction
is a whole lot is starting in the
denominator is smaller the fraction as a
whole this is large off anyway how do I
get this to have the same denominator is
that I'm multiplying top and bottom by
101 that sort of bumped up the factorial
from 100 factorial to 101 factorial
right well have a look at this how do I
change these two or which one do I
change in order to have the same
denominator well if I multiply this
fraction here by R + 1 on the top and r
plus 1 on the bottom okay see what I'm
doing there now if I just think about
this part here that R plus 1 times R
factorial that is R plus 1 times R times
R minus 1 it's on all the way down
that's a plus 1 factorial right so what
I've got now having adjusted the top and
bottom is I've got the numerator now
matching sorry the denominator I'm
matching between this fraction and well
at least this part is fine okay now
we're going to employ a very similar
trick to work out how do I make this n
minus R minus 1 and M minus R minus 2
how am I going to get them to be
equivalent well which one is a bigger
factorial which one starts with a bigger
number well n minus R minus 1 will be
bigger than n minus R minus 2 just like
say you know 10 minus 1 is bigger than
ten minus two nice big name okay so
therefore what I need to do is I need to
multiply this one by the next term along
and the factorial the next 10 along is n
minus R minus 1 okay so if I chuck an N
minus R minus 1 on the front there okay
I also have an N minus 1 factorial don't
ignore that what's going to happen well
that R plus 1 factorial we've already
accounted for
but this ad - aren't minus 2 factorial
now that it's got the next term along in
the factorial sort of expansion it's
going to become this so now I have the
same to notice this is excellent ok
right so how do i how do I put these
together well if the denominators are
the same then all I need to do is put
together numerator so I have R plus 1 n
minus 1 factorial and then I've got n
minus R minus 1 n minus 1 factorial all
over this common denominator which I've
determined right ok
still looks messy but now that we've got
them as one fraction we've made a big
step okay this is this is we've made a
lot of progress here so how can we make
this simpler because remember what I
wanted to end up at I wanted to end up
at this which is really really simple
ok so on the top here I notice I have
this common factor right n minus 1
factorial so I'll slap that out the
front and then what do I have
multiplying that by I've got a plus 1
there right and here I've got n minus R
minus 1 now look carefully at what I
have on the right-hand side of the
numerator here okay I'm plus 1 that's
fine but there's a minus R and a minus 1
so these terms are exactly two can't
slap the are with the minus R and the
one with the minus 1 so all left with is
n now hold on a second
I've just been doing this kind of trick
to adjust the denominators right I know
what happens when you've got a number
times a number minus 1 factorial this is
just the next step along in a factorial
right so I can just write that as n
factorial on o plus 1 factorial n minus
1 ok ok so this looks pretty good this
is pretty simple right is it simple
enough well let's have a look back on
track
right what was I trying to get this is
the right hand side that's what that's
what I started with right I want to get
it equal to the left hand side and shoes
are plus one okay now what is n choose R
plus one well based on this definition
right it should be if I have instead of
n choose R by n choose R plus one
that'll be a plus one
this R will become R plus 1 and this n
minus R factorial will become you know
this the R plus one would become would
be in the brackets here
so would become n minus R minus 1 the
the plus one becomes a negative because
of that minus sign there okay so this
will become n minus R minus 1 factorial
now have a look at what we've arrived at
I've got the N factorial on top I've got
the R plus 1 factorial over here and
that's the N minus R minus 1 okay if you
wanted to make it super obvious you can
say that's n factorial on R plus 1
factorial and minus plus 1 just watch
your brackets there okay and that is by
definition and choose R plus 1 that's
the left hand side okay therefore the
identity is true so that's it that was
the approach ok what we did was we are
we took this which looks a bit
intimidating and all we needed to really
do was expand these binomial terms okay
and be able to recognize what do they
really stand for and how do we work with
them to simplify okay